if the Earth was overrun by horrifying
curses and whoever learns to control
them can become the world's most
powerful being what would you do your
sweet girlfriend has died and
transformed into a vicious curse and one
of the world's most powerful Sorcerers
wants you dead I'm going to break down
the mistakes made what you should do and
how to beat the master of curses in to
Jutsu Kaizen zero this boy doesn't know
it yet but his ability to keep the
ladies interested is about to make him
the target of the most powerful cult
leader he will have to become a master
swordsman learn about the brand new
world of curses and keep his dead
girlfriend happy in order to survive an
all-out War Utah is cornered in a
classroom by a bunch of bullies who
threatened to hurt him but before the
bullies can even touch him he calls out
to a girl named Rika and suddenly some
bony claws wrap around Mr Bully's face
and yank him into the darkness Yuta
curls into a ball apologizing while the
bullies are stuffed into a cabinet and
are given a brand new meaning to the
term meets Locker why is it looking at
me it looks just like a meatball Yuta
feels so bad that he agrees with some
powerful leaders who want to execute him
and cover up his powers gee that's nice
luckily this blindfolded man can see
something that others don't even though
he's blindfolded and offers to take you
to in this man is satoru goja a teacher
at Jujutsu high school a school for some
very special students who have powers
just like Utah he tells the boy that a
curse has been placed on him but he is
capable of learning to use the curse to
do good and serve people and you know
great power comes great responsibility
and all that jazz a Newton's first day
he meets the only three other students
at school gee I wonder how they get
funding and they are called to him at
first especially this girl Maki and the
frosty reception gets downright sharp
and nasty when Maki slams her weapon
into the board beside Utah the other
students demanded you to leave because
they can see that he is cursed and has
brought a curse entity in with him the
boy is very confused and looks downright
terrified and Gojo shows up in the nick
of time to explain that curses are real
and have been responsible for many of
the Unexplained death happening around
the country each year curse users with
evil intentions can use curses or cursed
items to carry out their no-good evil
Deeds the school is where students who
have powers can learn about curses and
just like somewhere in the Vatican learn
how to exercise them the other students
are a little bit peeved that Gojo only
explains curses to you to now but
someone else is even more mad yuta's
curse a jealous little thing not really
it's a massive white creature named Rika
and she emerges and demands that the
other students treat Yuta well or else
and side note everybody Rika wasn't
always this way six years ago she was
sweet ordinary a human and someone who
thought Utah was our real cutie pie and
wanted to be his girlfriend Yay good for
him and she gives you to a ring calling
it an engagement ring ooh that's forward
and makes him promise that they'll get
married one day look how happy she yes
no one can say no to that face look
better Utah is no exception and accepts
her proposal but even before he has time
to check out his new ring and demand one
with a larger Stone I mean come on look
at this thing it's tiny Rika is killed
in a car accident and She lays dying in
the street Yuta calls out to her and
this is when Rika emerges from a puddle
of blood and the Mysterious wide
creature vowing to stay with her
boyfriend forever appears just like she
promised okay am I hearing this right
now this boy agreed to be executed
before even trying to find out if he can
persuade Rika to leave sending a little
bit of a disconnect in his brain
synapses here he has a girlfriend who
died and then turned into a monstrous
creature I mean that's a pretty clear
indication that this Supernatural deal
is real yet it looks like Utah didn't
even bother asking around or searching
to Google about this brand new world
affecting his life he doesn't even know
curses existed till Gojo spoon fed him
that information gee thanks because
apparently Yuta is an idiot Rika was a
reasonable girl when she was alive
though maybe she was secretly crazy and
even now her cursed form clearly cares
about him and would do what he asks you
hope the boy should try to let her down
easy and see if he can make it a it's a
mean of you kind of thing and have her
leave on her own letting her know the
truth that many powerful people now want
him dead because she is too much of a
clingy girlfriend and way too much of a
threat to regular Society yeah that
would be a good place to start Rika will
certainly not want her boyfriend to live
a miserable life being hunted down and
ostracized from others for the rest of
his days and may try to give him a
little bit of a normal life if that
doesn't work it's still worth a shot for
you to try telling her that he needs to
be free of distractions not having dead
classmates get stuffed into lockers and
maybe it tells it that he wants her to
find peace or any other type of liar
excuse that he can think up to make or
leave at least for a little bit I mean
arrange a schedule haunt me from 1pm
till five or seven a.m to 9 A.M I mean
there's ways to figure this out right
though personally I would say maybe
sharing my life's collection of Lego and
Star Wars rookie fan fiction cards along
with maybe some anime figurines like
just be a sure far away to become single
again I mean come on if I overload her
with the Wii been the nerd I don't think
her brain can handle it but even if all
these other efforts fail it might not be
such a bad thing Yuta has just heard
from his teacher that curses are
responsible for thousands of deaths each
year and curse users can use their power
to affect those around them I mean there
is obviously a thriving culture and a
market for curses out there among cursed
users if Rika won't leave me alone if I
was Yuta I could make the best of this
situation and use her powers to improve
my life I mean it kind of sucks but who
wouldn't want a clingy massive strong
creature ready to obey their every
command mostly As long as Yuta would
stop being so terrified of her and learn
to treat Rika like a partner who can do
tough jobs for him because clearly he
can't he could really use her ghosty
muscle to get super rich the boy has a
kind heart and would likely be happy if
he can start his own Protection Agency
loaning out rika's services for people
afraid that they are being followed or
targeted see look at that business model
you're welcome I mean come on one look
at rika's rays of sharp pearly whites as
enough to send any wannabe stalker
running for the hills once where it
spreads that Utah offers the best
bodyguard protection in town his
business can take on Rich celebrities
and VIPs the boy can then use all that
sweet money to get his girlfriend a
fresh ghosty manicure on those Claws and
all he has to do is to be willing to go
a little on the dark side for his own
game I mean if the protection gig
doesn't work out he could even set Rika
to rob banks or beat up his enemies for
him life's already dealt him with such a
crappy hand brought on by rika's own
making so I say since his dead
girlfriend is around the least he can do
is become super rich and Powerful kojo
reminds the other students to be nice to
Utah so Rika won't beat them up from the
looks of things though it's already too
late Rika has already taken these
students well back to school with a few
good Wallops the teacher moves things
along by officially introducing Yuta to
his classmates this angry girl Maki is a
cursed tool user who specializes in
using weapons against curses the choir
boy Toge is a cursed speech user who can
only speak in Rice Bowl ingredients
weird his curses and the fluffiest of
the fluffies of the boys is the panda a
talking panda I'm not even kidding Gojo
pairs the students up for their first
assignment putting you to end Marquee
together and from the look on maki's
face it's clear that the girl is just
Overjoyed to have the new boy as her
partner great she spends the next few
minutes berating Yuta for being too
passive and too much of a goody goody
two-shoes telling him that he needs to
toughen up if he wants to survive in
this school Gojo takes the pair to a
nearby Elementary School where some
children have gone missing he explains
that this is likely the work of a curse
Maggie says the curses tend to settle or
even get born in places where bad
memories or emotions occur the teacher
chants some words and places over a veil
over the school basically something that
will help smoke out curses and keep
everything looking normal to people
outside of the veil Gojo then just
leaves the teenagers on their own to
exercise the school almost instantly the
pair spots some creatures nearby and
monkey says that they are low-level
curses who tend to group together she
charges towards them and easily Cuts
them down with her pull arm entering the
school Utah looks absolutely terrified
and just about as eager as he would walk
into an executive convention it's that
bad and just like an executive
convention this school is filled with
Hideous looking beings lurking around
every Corner these are the many curses
plaguing the school but they are not
attacking for some reason Maggie
explains that Jujutsu sorcers are ranked
with grades one to four with rank 1
students having the most potential and
she demands to see you to student card
and is very surprised to see that he's
been ranked special grade the girl can't
even believe it special grades are
rarely given out and reserved only for
the most powerful of Jujutsu sorceress
but out of nowhere an extra chunky curse
attacks the pair and Maki tries to slash
it but it grows to the size of the
school and swallows them whole inside of
the curse's belly Maki is furious even
more so when she realizes that she has
dropped her weapon outside and they spot
two little boys inside of the creature's
stomach with them these are the missing
Elementary School students who are badly
hurt and scared monkey explains that
they will have no choice but to wait
outside for help hoping that someone
eventually will lift the veil and come
rescue them and she is already feeling
the effects of the curse and passes out
to Utah's horror he sees that a wound on
her leg has already begun to get
infected with cursed energy okay
assuming what Maki says is right then
this this massive curse was likely born
out of trauma or bad memories that the
elementary students have about their
school the first thing Yuta should do is
to figure out if the curse is linked to
either one of the two boys or both of
them and figure out if they're linked in
the same way that Rika is linked to him
drawing from his own experience he
should know that anyone who accidentally
summoned a curse would likely be very
very remorseful and say things like I'm
sorry I didn't mean to you I mean oops
you know along those lines he should
talk to the boys and see if either of
them is acting in this way or if they
have suffered unresolved trauma on the
school grounds the person responsible
will likely display a special connection
to the curse being even able to change
the curse's behavior during periods of
heightened emotions or have memories of
a horrific personal event which happened
to them at this school seeing that Rika
retains her voice and some aspects of
her personality her ego even in her
cursed form he right there has a lead on
the curses haunting and why it's here in
the elementary school and if I'm him I
know that most likely the figure at the
center of all of this is probably some
grotesque evil looking man with a
destructive personality he should ask
the boys about controlling male figures
in their lives and see if this curse was
born out of their trauma and also Yuta
better hope he finds something out from
these boys because he cursed with an
innocent Master can be much more easily
controlled than a wild curse if Yuta
manages to trace this curse back to one
of the boys he could then teach the boys
to manage the curse like how he controls
rika's rage and could even probably get
them into Jujutsu High because at this
point if I'm him I know that my crazy
dead girlfriend only emerges when I'm in
danger or feeling super stressed I need
to make the boys feel safe and reassure
them not to panic because in doing that
it would cause the curse to most likely
calm down once they get out of this mess
you Tahir should start giving himself a
little bit more credit Marquis just told
him that there are only four ranks that
normal Jujutsu Sorcerers can fall under
at his special rank surpasses them all
this means that he is actually a big
deal at his life's approach of trying to
keep a low profile is not going to work
anymore special ranked Sorcerers are one
of the rarest types of people in the
world and he can expect a life full of
others turning to him for advice or to
issue a challenge if I I'm Yuta I need
to approach Gojo the most powerful
sorcerer that I know and the closest
thing that he has to another special
ranked user and the guy probably is I
mean come on we all know he is don't lie
we know and I know that this guy must
have some tips for me if I'm Yuta so I
can better Channel or control my power
or my girlfriend for example would
yuta's curses level up if he starts to
wear blindfolds like his teacher would
he turn into Daredevil I wonder would
that allow him to better Channel his
cursed energy I mean come on regardless
of how goofy he comes across Gojo is
very powerful and will likely have a lot
of useful advice to pass down onto Utah
growing more desperate monkey pushes
Yuta to explain his motivation for
coming to the school the boy explains
that he just wants to do good and feel
needed by others in a rare moment of
encouragement Maki tells him to keep
trying hard assuring him that friends
and confidence will naturally fall into
place once he gets to better know and
control his powers suddenly inspired and
in the moment Yuta puts on rika's ring
and calls on her for help and this crazy
I mean creature rushes over faster than
a hungry dog hearing a bag of treats
Russell and suddenly Rico grows massive
and burst first out of the curse's belly
ripping it to shreds and sending chunks
splattering all over the school and Veil
gross and the two of them leave while
the girlfriend has the time of her life
at the bloodbath above nice due to
drag's monkey and the two boys out of
the school to safety at the school Gojo
is impressed at the boy's power and
heroism you to tells the teachers that
he has come to a realization he thinks
that it wasn't Rika who cursed him and
that it was his grief over her death
that accidentally cursed her to become
bound to him instead he vows to learn
all he can about curses at Jujutsu high
so that he can one day break rika's
curse and set her free oh he's so nice
sometime later the Jujutsu leaders are
mad that Gojo has failed to contain
yuta's Powers properly they point out
that Rika was allowed to be Unleashed
for way too long and that occurs of such
a man's power is a threat to them all
the leaders once again pushed to execute
the boy for being too powerful but Gojo
defends him he tells the leaders that he
has the matter under control and will
side with his student if they ever try
to hurt him back at the school Gojo
gives Yuta a katana and advises him to
give of its power by transferring his
cursed energy to it a little bit at a
time instead of unleashing Rika fully
this will help you to have better
control over his curse and reduce the
risk that Rika will get out of control
and hurt innocent people Utah trains a
recovered Maki and come to find out
she's a very skilled fighter and he is
no match for her at first at all Utah is
determined to improve and asks if they
can go another round and the girl is
really happy to indulge him because it
means another chance to wipe the floor
with him as they Spar Panda Boy
interrupts and teases Maki he implies
that the girl has a crush on Yuta and
she is furious and doesn't even deny it
though and Yuta seems totally clueless
about their conversation because that's
the way it goes in anime and instead
goes to Gojo about his next assignment
Gojo tells him that he will be
supporting Toge on a mission at the
shopping district the teacher explains
that toge's power of cursed speech is
the perfect fit for this assignment and
asks that you to go along to learn from
him before the boys leave on their
mission though kojo tells Yuta that no
matter what happens he cannot fully
unleash Rika gosh isn't that such an
annoying thing about anime somehow the
main character here has yet again
completely forgotten way too quickly
that he saved the day at the elementary
school if not for him Maki and the two
boys might still be missing to this day
though I'm sure that Gojo would have
saved them in the nick of time but
seriously come on Gojo seems to like to
wait at the last minute don't you think
so I say the boy should have no shame in
milking the Positive Vibes out of this
thing for all that it's worth he could
even seize the opportunity to visit the
two boys at their homes offer some words
of encouragement to their families and
let the parents know that he will always
be there to support their sons though
I'm pretty sure their parents might be a
little weirded out considering that this
is probably someone that the boys have
no connection to and really have no
reason why that Utah should know their
sons but assuming the parents know the
situation I'm sure they'd already be
very grateful to Utah for saving their
sons and going this extra mile to
schmooze up to them will likely win him
some allies and possibly some food and
also if it works out those people the
parents and the kids will become very
valuable advocates for him in the future
should anyone ever suggest that his
power is dangerous and that he should be
executed in the interest of Public
Safety if the panel of jujutsu's
sorceress thinks they are powerful they
clearly have not seen the sheer reach
and influence of mom groups I mean have
you looked at it it's terrifying they're
all over the place by winning just over
one or two parents Yuta is sending out
metaphorical seeds into the world
Advocates if you will who can now share
the touching personal story of how he is
a hero and should be cherished by
Society I mean look at the guy he
already has Maki crushing on him and
it's practically five seconds into the
movie and Rika is hopelessly devoted to
him for life well afterlife and with all
this good press and maybe even a larger
Public Image Yuta could easily over time
become a beloved public figure and once
he's a household to name with thousands
of rabid fans ready to defend him at a
moment's notice I'm pretty sure it's not
gonna be so easy to suggest that he gets
executed ever again and speaking of
gaining fans and winning people over all
three of Utah's fellow students seem
ready to be his best friend and source
of information he just needs to push the
right buttons their friendships will be
very valuable because Gojo and the
school board clearly have their own
agenda which they know to keep from Utah
so his fellow students are the only
other Jiu Jitsu Sorcerers who can be
open to him about what they know about
the Jiu Jitsu culture or use in cursed
energy and by becoming the most popular
guy in a very very tiny school Utah
needs to recognize that almost everyone
tends to respond to the type of
persuasion which best matches their
personality and persuasion methods all
fall somewhere on a sliding scale of
charm to intimidation some people are
more open to trust you when you've
ladder them and compliment them like oh
I love your dress oh thank you I'll be
your friend whereas others would like
you to take charge give them clear
orders to follow open your soul to me
okay that sort of thing with Marquee for
example she has already expressed her
disgust at Utah for being weak and
soft-spoken on the other hand though
before she collapsed at the elementary
school she did tell him that she has
certain vulnerabilities to Cursed energy
which he does not this suggests that
Maki would be open to trust someone who
is confident and assertive but who can
offer her protection in the areas where
she is weaker and wants Utah wins over
his new best friends it's gonna be far
harder for anyone else to Target him or
take advantage of his inexperience with
curses at the shopping district Toge
gets himself some throat spray to
prepare for the mission just like I do
when I prepare for a voiceover moving on
one once the veil is drawn the boys spot
hundreds of tiny curses swarming
together in the middle of the district
finally using his cursed speech Powers
Toge shouts at them commanding them to
explode the curses are incinerated
instantly and fall to the ground dead
but this comes with a price the quiet
boys left with a hoarse voice and a sore
throat from using his powers thinking
the mission is over the boys walk up to
the veil but notice that it is not
lifting and out of nowhere a powerful
curse appears behind them and this
creature is very powerful and can summon
energy beams from above to zap them into
charcoal's barbecue quiet boy pushes
Yuta out of the way and uses the last of
his strength to disfigure the creature's
arm but it isn't enough the curse
attacks again and forces the boys to
retreat hiding from the curse Utah sees
that his friend is injured from saving
his life and Toge can also barely speak
and use his powers and desperately needs
some more throat spray but it's not his
fault because he lost it when the cursed
attacked idiot Toge is determined to
return and face the creature alone but
Yuta refuses to leave his friend Utah
charges at the curse with his Katana
managing to wound it further but unable
to overpower it realizing that he can't
beat the curse without unleashing Rika
fully the boy instead decides to
retrieve his friend's throat spray and
tosses it to the quiet boy and that
magic spray cures his sore voice and
restores his powers and Toge rushes back
into the battle and commands for the
cursor's head to be crushed and it
instantly kills the creature the boys
reunite and encourage each other over a
job well done with a cool crisp high
five but like total anime idiots they
don't notice that someone else is
watching them as they leave the
mysterious figure picks up yuta's
student card and sees that he is a
special grade sorcerer
some time later Gojo speaks with his
associates about what went wrong he
learns that someone placed a second Veil
over the shopping district trapping the
boys inside with unexpectedly powerful
curse the teacher says that he can sense
who the mysterious person is and the one
who caused this is suguru ghetto the
evil man is a special grade sorcerer
himself and became a cult leader after
being banished from Jujutsu High Gojo
explains that ghetto has cursed over 100
people to their deaths using his immense
Powers at Kyoto's headquarters he is
approached for Help by a mother and a
daughter who thinks they may be cursed
the the man is super rude to them even
insisting on renaming the woman for his
own amusement and he spots a creepy
leering curse around the younger woman's
neck and easily draws it away from her
turning it into a ball of energy which
he keeps okay I'm just gonna point
something out rather obvious Toge here
should really stop speaking into Rice
Bowl ingredients it's a little weird and
it's now has left him about as smart as
alternative look at this he's kind of
dumb his entire power depends on him
keeping his voice so it's definitely not
a good idea to buy Dollar Store throat
spray seconds before a mission I mean
buy the good stuff man get what I use
dude it works so much better and you
want to know why it works better because
it's not the kind of brand of throat
spray that tends to LEAP out of one's
hands when attacked by a giant Sky beam
in fact having to hold on to a
convenience store baggie with a plastic
bottle inside is one of the least cool
things that this guy can do while
gallantly charging into battle but I do
like it though for some reason but
really for something that can make the
difference between life and death he
should not have wasted precious seconds
fishing into the bag for the bottle and
capping the lid then lining up the spray
at the very least Toge could have a
better method he should keep his
life-saving medicine somewhere far easy
easier to get to for example if he
funnels one dose of the medicine into a
waterproof plastic capsule where you can
store it in his mouth like one of those
poison capsules that spies hide in their
teeth in case they get captured and then
when he feels like his voice is starting
to break and then slip away from him
during a fight he can simply bite down
hard break the capsule releasing the
soothing medicine and re-sustain his
voice sorry I got a little excited
moving on if I were either of these two
boys I would also be very concerned that
someone is trying very hard to set us up
to be killed two things went wrong with
this mission that don't have an easy
explanation the veil trapped everyone
inside and could not be lifted by anyone
this suggests that the associate who
helped set up the veil may be in on the
scheme or at the very least had his own
magic overpowered because since the veil
requires someone with magical skill set
to set it up the boy should send their
teacher back to the scene to see if he
can detect any lingering mystical
energies see if he can find traces of
the owner of that magic next thing I
want to bring up is that despite the
school doing some reconnaissance
beforehand there was a high level curse
which no one detected waiting to kill
Yuta and Toge inside of the mission area
this suggests suggests that whoever set
them up is a high-level jiu Jutsu
sorcerer themselves and capable of
summoning curses of that level and since
their teacher mentions that this mission
was exactly suited for togei's powers
and something that he could do
unsupervised as a level 2 Jujutsu
sorcerer they should also be very
suspicious that the whole mission was a
fake setup to catch the boys alone but
that also means that whoever set this up
is familiar with students who do
exorcisms as well as know the school's
protocols very well which means we gotta
create a list folks former Jujutsu High
alumni teachers board members would Zoom
right to the top of my suspect list I
would cross-reference that list with
sorcerer's powerful enough to summon
high-level curses which should narrow
down the possible culprits down to just
a handful of suspects and then like Gojo
already said we would come to realize
that we're dealing with ghetto much
sooner the sleazeball ghetto complains
to his associate that all normal humans
are monkeys who are weak and he has no
respect for walking back inside he
encounters a former client who is
suffering from a deadly curse and begs
him for help the evil sorcer Ace the
ball of energy he collected from the
curse that he previously exercised right
in front of the man but refuses to help
him he says that he hates regular people
and has no interest in helping them
unless they can pay him handsomely which
this client has not done in some time
and ghetto just stands there and watches
in Glee as the curses tear the Man Apart
killing him at Jujutsu High the four
students see a giant bird approaching
them from the sky and it lands right in
front of them with ghetto and his
followers emerging from its mouth the
evil sorcerer takes a special interest
in Utah he walks right up to the boy and
grabs him by the hands the man explains
that people like them are superior to
all the non-sorcerers on Earth and that
regular people do not deserve the help
or protection of Jujutsu sorceress that
has been given to them for decades he
asks that you to join him in his class
to wipe out all the regular people so
that Sorcerers like them can take over
the world the man also scoffs and Maki
calling her a big failure which
unsettles the girl Yuta slaps his hand
away saying that he does not intend to
side with anyone who insults his friends
but then Gojo interrupts demanding to
know why the evil sorcerer has come into
their school ghetto says that his come
to declare war on all of them he says
that him and his followers intend to
unleash dozens of deadly curses into
heavily populated areas within Tokyo and
Kyoto in order to wipe out all the
regular humans calling it The Night
parade of a hundred demons he also
challenges Gojo and his students to come
fight them if they can when they unleash
their plans if they can fight them that
is just then one of gaito's followers
whines about wanting Crepes from a cafe
before it closes so one of the bad guys
do the evil sorcerer turns to leave
inviting the stunned friends to fight
him at his parade of demons later Gojo
tries to stop him from leaving but
ghetto summons a monstrous giant curse
he threats to attack the students with
his curses unless the teacher lets him
go Gojo backs off and the Sorcerer And
his followers Escape getting ready to
prepare for the upcoming War the
associates of Jujutsu High hold a
briefing on this evil man and his powers
finding out that the man has established
a new religion and gathered many
followers to his cult and they all
benefit from ghetto's power of being
able to collect curses like Pokemon
which is kind of cool but it makes him
really powerful the panel estimates the
ghetto may have over 2 000 curses
collected and Power bring him up the
school's principal insists that they
meet ghetto's Declaration of Warhead on
demanding that they call out to all
Jujutsu Clans and school alumni
Gathering Up Older allies to take a
final stand against this evil cult okay
okay I know everything's super serious
right now but am I the only one that
smells Something Fishy here this
annoying girl is glued to her phone and
just threw a tantrum about wanting food
from a famous cafe does this seem like
the type of person who generally wants
the world to end if the followers of
this evil cult truly wanted to kill all
regular people they would not be so
openly materialistic which means they
need these peasants to keep cafes
running to keep their phones on to
enable them to continue leading a
luxurious lifestyle gaito's motivation
doesn't make sense at all how can he and
his followers be sick of being held back
by regular people or having to help them
all the time when that is not what their
cult is doing at all they're already
leading successful self-centered lives
devoted to material pleasures and have
no reason to risk their lives to try and
change things Gojo said it himself
there's no way his enemy would get into
a fight unless he has a very major
certainty that he would win declaring
war on Jujutsu high and attacking
civilians in major cities will bring not
only very good Jujutsu sorcers down on
his head but it will also piss off
Japan's military and seriously you don't
want to mess with these guys not only
are they formatable power with the
absolute latest in the state-of-the-art
Weaponry this year alone Japan has a
military budget of around 55 billion
dollars
75 billion dollars oh my gosh no matter
how powerful the cult thinks they are no
one can be absolute confident in going
up against an entire country that has an
almost Limitless military budget this
kind of sounds like the opposite of a
war that ghetto can be confident that he
can win and this means that the evil
sorcerer is not telling them the truth
about his motives without understanding
what he really wants this Jujutsu
Council should avoid playing into their
hands and act on their instincts of
going to war with the cult like ghetto
wants you to here is somebody that he
has shown a lot of interest in in
winning over despite being a new student
a complete nobody the evil sorcerer
obviously has plans for the boy ghetto
called Maki a monkey even though she is
a fellow Jujutsu sorcerer because her
powers are weak and this is the term
that he uses to insult regular people
with and uses it to dismiss their worth
if he doesn't treat you to the same way
despite him being the most inexperienced
one here this means that he sees value
in winning you to over to his side if
yuti gives Geto a call right now and
tells him his points are starting to
make a lot of sense how the evil
sorcerer reacts might give Clues to his
true intention let's say he asks Yuta to
spy on the school for him or show up on
the front line of battle to fight for
him that means he sees the boys just
another Pawn whose power he wants on his
side to better his odds but if he asks
the boy to join him beforehand or meet
him privately this suggests that what
Getta wants is to kidnap or kill Utah
that the boy can be used as bait back at
his cult headquarters ghetto tells his
followers that he thinks they only have
a 30 chance of survival if they truly
went to war with the rest of the country
even less if the Jujutsu Society rallies
against them and this devious man has an
ace up his sleeve though of course he
does getto shares that if he manages to
kill Yuta and control Rika for himself
his team's chances leap up to 99 he is
counting on Gojo being too afraid to
bring Yuta and Rika into a fight into a
populated area which by the way would
leave the boy all alone and unguarded
while everyone else is fighting and you
know what happens folks Utah indeed gets
left behind a jiu jitsu high with Maki
because the others think that they're
just too inexperienced to join the war
and finally with some alone time Maki
opens up to the boy and she tells him
that she's come from a long line of
Jujutsu so Source but has always felt
like she had to prove herself because
she has less naturally talented than the
rest of her family she can't even see
curses and has to rely on special
glasses to spot them her cursed weapons
are also imbued with energy by other
people and all the girl can do is be a
good fighter she can hardly use cursed
energy on her own but Maki nonetheless
vows to one day rise to become a
powerful sorceress and prove her family
wrong destroying them from within in the
city Gojo and his team have mostly
evacuated the civilians the cult
followers tell each other to watch out
for the teacher because he is the most
powerful opponent here and they remind
each other that they only have to stall
for time their plan is to not win but to
serve as a distraction solar leader has
enough time to attack the school and
kill Yuta Gojo senses something is wrong
and catches on the ghetto plans to
attack Yuta at the school the Teacher
Calls Panda and Toge over telling them
that he is sending them back to the
school to protect Yuta and the man uses
his powers to teleport them back to
Jujutsu high back at the school ghettos
already started his attack badly
injuring Maki and leaving the girl
bleeding on the roof Panda and Toge
attacked the man but they are quickly
overwhelmed by the thousands of curses
he has collected by the time you finds
his friends on the roof all three of
them like crushed and injured the boy is
devastated to see his friends so close
to death in a moment of rage he ignores
Gojo's advice and unleashes Rika on the
evil sorcerer and a massive battle
erupts between the curses the boy
escapes with his friends and uses his
magic to start healing them Rika briefly
gets jealous that Yuta is showing
concern for Maki another girl but he
assures her that the only enemy here is
ghetto and Yuta prepares to fight the
man again Kyoto apologizes to him
telling him that it's nothing personal
he just needs Rika more than you to dust
bro you better have caught that ghetto
here is getting way too arrogant and he
just let his master plan slip he intends
to take control of Rika for himself and
says the man left the main battle in the
city to come after Utah Rika must be
pivotal to his plans on world domination
Utah cannot let this happen they both
know that Rika is deeply in love with
Utah and would never willingly follow
another Sorcerer And this means that
ghetto intends to kill the boy it's the
only shot he has to add Rika to his
collection of curses which means Yuta is
in a real pickle how do we get him out
of this one cannot unleash Rika without
causing widespread damage to the city
around him and any innocent people who
may be nearby including his three
unconscious friends and even worse his
teacher didn't keep him in the loop the
boy knows that ghetto is very powerful
and has collected thousands of curses
which he intends to use against his
enemies and no one really has a good
idea how this curse collecting power
works unlike curse tools or cursed
speech which Jujutsu high school
students use and are familiar with
ganto's curse collecting power is a big
mystery for all we know he will be able
to snap his fingers and in prison Rika
the moment she appears the risk to Yuta
and everyone here is too hot it may not
look Gallant but Utah's best option here
is to actually run away for all of his
talents ghetto does not have any
powerful tracking ability as far as
anyone knows both times he has found
Yuta and it was because he had visited
Jujutsu High where it was obvious the
boy would be there he went to the roof
and didn't even attack Yuta right away
after arriving at the school despite the
boy being his main target the evil
sorcerer may be able to zoom around at
superhuman speeds given his abilities
but this shows that his abilities to
track specific people are weak at best
if we take a look at the the area
surrounding the school we will see that
the area is surrounded by forests and
mountains yute here should partially
release Rika a little bit and make her
very happy by riding her at Breakneck
speeds into the surrounding Force the
heavy vegetation will break the line of
sight and provide heavy cover there
might be even be tiny caves or root
system within a tree or somewhere in the
mountains where a very skinny boy such
as him could fit into but they're too
small for ghetto that Beefcake and once
Utah has managed to put some distance
between himself and the evil sorcerer he
should split up from Rika to trick the
map Gojo was previously able to pick up
a weak sense of ghetto's presence at the
shopping district but that means that
ghetto might have a similar sensing
ability and if these abilities pick up
on cursed energy it will likely pick up
the aura from Rika and not Yuta which
will allow ghetto to track Rita down
which isn't ideal but at least she can
handle herself and will never willingly
defect to his side but if ghetto finds
Yuta it'll be a complete disaster
because he will kill the boy and take
Rika for himself Yuta has got to lay low
and tell Rika to dial her power from 100
to about 2 percent dial it down so they
can hide and eventually make it back to
his friend friends who hopefully Aren't
Dead the night parade of 100 demons
rages on in the city as members of the
Jujutsu Society Battle with ghetto's
followers and their dozens of curses
these two 15 year old girls are part of
the cult insisting that they are loyal
to the evil sorcerer because they had a
tough childhood and he was the only one
who took them in and taught them the
ways of his cult and they get ready to
viciously attack one of the Jujutsu High
School Associates as if he stole the
last ticket to a Justin Bieber concert
the passion is insane but just then
they're interrupted by Gojo finding
another member of the cult this cult
follower Miguel uses a dark rope as his
weapon and is the only one who comes
close to challenging Gojo's power and
the teacher starts to take his
blindfolds off revealing that a lot of
his power resides in his eyes Miguel
unleashes many curses on the man but
they are no match for him but neither is
Miguel himself Gojo beats him badly and
pummels them all the way across the city
elsewhere the other members of the
Jujutsu Society are holding their own
against cult members and their curses
and many curses are being taken out but
more and more keep coming the fighters
do their best to hold them at Bay at the
school and Unleashed Rika and Katana
wielding Yuta team up on Ghetto the man
continues speaking about how cursed
users are superior to regular people he
thinks it's a huge Injustice that strong
people like him can still get
overwhelmed and dragged down by the weak
regular people do to their sheer numbers
he wants to create a perfect world where
no regular people exist and he no longer
has to feel the burden of their presence
picking up on uh that the man is
completely insane Yuta tells him that he
has no choice but to kill ghetto but the
evil sorcerer will not go down that
easily he unleashes the most powerful
special grade curse that he has in
combination with the other
4461 curses that he has collected over
months the evil curses combined to form
a dark swirling storm over ghetto's head
and he prepares to hurl it at Utah with
no other choice the boy turns to Rika he
thanks her for being his girlfriend and
protector and Promises to die and spend
eternity with her if she can just lend
him her powers one more time him
declaring his love releases all limits
on rika's cursed energy and ghetto sends
the black swirling storm of energy
towards Utah Rika unleashes a freaking
Supernova of a blinding beam of light
towards the man and the Clash of these
two super Powers causes a massive
explosion destroying all nearby
buildings and makes a huge crater in the
ground beneath the school When the Smoke
Clears ghetto wanders the street
mortally wounded one of his arms had
been ripped off and the man is dying
Gojo returns and sees the state that his
old friend is in he reveals that it was
his plan all along to send panda and
Toge back to the school knowing Gator
would beat them he had counted on Utah
being motivated to unleash his full
Powers after seeing his friends hurt
okay there's no way that that just
worked apart from killing Jeju to
highest chances of winning architecture
digest least crater a school award you
to actually managed to beat Ghetto by
taking him on directly it should never
have come to this though the boy put
himself at an unnecessary risk and
turned a sure-win situation into a near
defeat you wouldn't count on the Rock to
win a knitting competition for you sorry
Mr Johnson so why the heck with this
scrawny 16 year old even tried to take
on this hulking Beefcake of a man in a
sword fight Utah's real strength is his
partnership with Rika and his Mastery of
cursed energy he knows he's exceptional
on this front since he has been branded
as a special grade sorcerer from the
start a very rare and top-tier grade on
the other hand Utah has only been
training and fighting with katana for a
few months and is only ever trained
against other inexperienced students
even then an average fighter like Maki
has managed to wipe the floor with him
on more than one occasion the boy should
have stuck to using Rika or blasting
ghetto with cursed energy from afar not
only is Rika insanely powerful she's
literally a living cursed nuclear power
plant and she is right at Utah's
fingertips and for that reason ghetto
will also pull his punches against her
the evil sorcer has made it super clear
that he wants to get Rika under his
control and that she is the final piece
of the puzzle in his plans to take over
the world and this means by Utah using
her this forces ghetto to pull it back
he won't be able to use his full Powers
against something that he wants to take
if he does he might damage it and ruin
his plans of taking over the world but
enough of that he should have realized
that he only needs her to buy some time
before reinforcements arrive he
successfully started healing his fellow
students so at any moment now two teens
and a very angry panda will be coming
back to his Aid so long as they don't
act like action movie henchmen and
attack him all at one time ghetto have
more than his hands full of fighting
four people at one months more
importantly everyone knows ghetto is the
cult's best warrior and only chance of
winning and this means that it is only a
matter of time before Gojo returns to
the school to confront ghetto after
realizing that he only needs to take out
the cult leader to end the war in Tokyo
and Kyoto for good and it also makes
even more sense that the teacher will be
returning to help very soon because once
he kills the leader the rest of the cult
is made up of petulant children and
sub-appar Fighters they're resolve in
their attacks on the city will dissolve
instantly so if you two can hold on and
use Rika for just a few minutes longer
all of his friends will arrive to join
forces with him and to feed the evil
sorcerer with much less Bloodshed with
his final breaths ghetto assures Gojo
that he never held any hatred towards
members of Jujutsu high he simply
couldn't bear living in a world with so
many people he considered inferior with
that Gojo advances on to the evil
Sorcerer And finally puts the man out of
his misery sending his old friend to a
better place once and for all or perhaps
somewhere much worse such as the pits of
hell but anyways nearby Utah comes to
and finds his three friends gathered
around him they're relieved that he is
okay but quickly grow concerned that
they realize that he had promised to die
with Rika in exchange for her help in
winning the battle but Riga appears
behind them and slowly her monstrous
form crumbles away to reveal the sweet
little girl that Yuta knew before she
died Gojo arrives and tells Yuta that he
was right all along the boy is the
descendant of a very powerful line of
Jujutsu sorceress and it was he who
accidentally cursed Rika in his grief
over her death but now that he has come
to terms with what had happened and what
he did the curse has been fully broken
Yuta breaks down and apologizes
profusely to Rika instead of being angry
Rika thanks him for giving her more time
with him she tells him that the six
years that she spent as a curse were the
happiest she's ever been uh this is a
little weird I mean I'm happy for her
but she literally just said that those
six years were the best she's ever had
and she's probably killed a few high
school students during that time you got
a crazy one Yuta you really do but
moving on from that Rika gives her
boyfriend her blessing to go on and live
a full life without her and gives him
one final hug before disappearing
finally moving on into the afterlight
later Gojo tells Yuta not to blame
himself for the destruction ghetto cost
he reassures him that the sorcerer would
have attacked the school either way he
returns you to his student card which
ghetto had passed back before his death
taking the card back you to prepare us
to leave with his friends now fully
single and ready to mingle